I believe in living what is in the heart
and finding what is in the heart and
serving the heart the heart is the
divine mind not the brain so if I wanted
that for myself which I do and I want
that for my children I had to want that
for my husband even though times were
hard I couldn't say well I'm finding my
divine voice and you go clock in at the
law firm and make everything fine so
somehow I knew because I had this
extreme faith I had this knowing in this
awareness that the way through these
challenges was to really find out what
was the truth of each of our hearts and
to do everything that we could to
fulfill that and that some way by some
grace by some miracle or some divine
intervention that somehow our lives
would be ordered in a way that it would
support that expression was there ever a
moment where you thought it was too much
and you were like this is not working
and I'm ready to give up there was one
moment and it was when we had almost
come through we were coming through and
it was when you dnf2 ultramen and you
relapsed and in the wake of that after
having held space for you for so many
years I mean through such adversity and
such friction and tension it was hard
for me to imagine that you would make
that choice because I'm not an addict
and I wasn't in that frame but at that
moment I had a moment where I was like
have I misjudged who riches have I
misjudged him because we're just
arriving out of this battle and we're
actually being realized and this is the
choice he made in that moment yeah that
was a low moment that was a rough that
was a rough experience to navigate
through I mean the level of like shame
and sense of disappointment that I had
that I'd let myself down and you down
and
whole plan down was very difficult but
in retrospect now having you know many
years passed since then like how do you
look back on that experience it was you
know it was still a hard moment I mean
it was a it was a moment of you know are
you kidding me quite frankly you
know it was you know super difficult I
mean again I've said it before I was
grateful for your community and AAA and
all the guys that you have around to you
so many beautiful men that are in your
life as a part of that program and you
know they were right there and you know
Tyler was there and you know you got you
know you got righted like right away
like it wasn't it wasn't a long it
wasn't a long spell in that but I do
remember arriving back from Hawaii and I
had supported you in your expression
through all of these years and I was a
gave birth to Jaya and was really sort
of in this seclusion at home with the
kids and doing ceremony and and
spiritual practices and ritual and
holding this vision for us and then
started creating the food and the
recipes and I had written two albums and
and become musician along with Tyler and
trapper our oldest sons and so I was
finally at the moment where I was going
to get to record my album and it had
been years it was seven years of working
workshopping these songs and so right
after that moment when we arrived back
home that was my turn that was when Brad
was coming here with his recording gear
we were setting up a studio in the house
I had him booked for ten days to two
weeks and we were recording my first
album so part of me what I did is I took
my anger and put it to the side because
I wasn't going to let that ruin my
experience of music so I sort of just
was like okay I don't like this and this
has really upset me and rich is fine now
and he's working it out and so I'm gonna
put this to the side for the moment and
I'm gonna focus on this creative
expression and then what happened is the
boys dad died suddenly and tragically on
day three of my recording session
so what I endured at the end of that
year 2011 was pretty staggering
I mean a pretty pretty intense sort of
energetic experience that I had to
traverse through after having held that
vision for us for so long and even
though I hadn't been with the boy's dad
for 14 years he was very close in their
lives and very close to me and I had to
process that grief through myself so it
was still many many months and many many
things before my music came to fruition
and by that time I guess we had just
worked it all out right yeah but I
suspect it made you a stronger person to
have to endure all of that and navigate
the difficulties of the complex
difficulties of loss anger creative
output parenting and just the general
responsibilities of having to you know
get through the day I mean even though
yes we were emerging from our financial
difficulties we were by no means out of
the woods at that point I mean there was
still quite a ways to go and we would
dip deeper before we kind of really
emerged out of it it's true it's true I
mean what I would say from my
perspective of that I would say that it
was a full experience of life that I
that I experienced and that experience
was full of heartbreak loss tragedy
triumph creative connection and the
weirdest thing was during the days
following the death of the boy's father
Lou I felt a simultaneous experience of
grief and birth and it's not something
that I've ever spoken about before I
probably never told you about this
before but it was a very profound
dichotomy of this juxtaposition of
extremes that are maybe the same thing
and so it was an extremely profound
potent really deep experience his exit
from this world was one of the most
profound experiences that I've had and
it's because there were all these
synchronicities and signs that were in
the music in people that I met just
coincidences and and in things that
happened during that time and I really
did feel the presence of divinity in
that space I felt that it was it was met
I remember when you were racing and
Ultraman Lou was texting me and he was
checking you he was following the race
and that was kind of a first because
it's not like we were just you know we
were really good getting divorced and
really took care of the children but
it's not like we were hanging out all
the time no I mean Lou wasn't Lou was
great but he wasn't like my buddy you
know we weren't friends but he was you
know kind and respectful and we you know
we all handled it like grown-ups you
know but it's not like we were taking
vacations together or something like
that so he was following your race in
those last days yeah he was texting me
and really excited and and all of that
and so I think that that it was just I
forgot my train of thought what I was
just saying but anyway it was a it was a
divinity in the experience yeah it was
very very divine I mean there were other
things that happened like Lou's first
cousin mine I was very close with her
and when I was married to him and I
hadn't talked to her in like we hadn't
been together for 14 years I didn't talk
to her for 14 years so when he passed we
were in contact and she couldn't attend
the memorial service that I facilitated
that I officiated here in our home you
know I told the boys now it's a healing
project that's basically what it is it's
a healing mission and we had everyone
come in you know from his life past
business associates past lovers wives
girlfriends you know everyone was here
all of his lovely covet cousins the
Pyatt family
in an amazing group of individuals and I
officiated that that process for all of
us and it was really really beautiful a
miner couldn't come because she had been
given she had bought a trip for her
girlfriend and they were going to kawaii
and everything had already been booked
and bought and everything else so at
that time Sol Rey who's a you know
well-known renowned yoga teacher that
you know I grew up in yoga with and he's
been a great Ally and a great friend to
me and to us he you know emailed here
texted me and he was like she meant to
you like could you come and cook for my
retreat and he said he knows that I have
a special connection to secret Beach on
kawaii
he said it's near secret Beach I don't
know if I'm asking too much but I think
it would be good and I could pay you we
needed money so I asked the boys and
they said go ahead and go mom so I went
there and I remember cooking completely
in grief and Saul would say what's on
the menu and I would say I have no idea
but something will be there and I
literally couldn't even make a menu list
because I was in such grief so my nakhon
tax me she's on kawaii at the same time
I haven't seen her in 14 years and I
said I'm I'm on the island meet me at
the Hindu temple at morning puja so I'm
sitting in the temple and she slides up
right next to me and we sit together for
puja and we took those flowers from the
offering from the priest that day and we
went down to secret beach and we walked
and we reminisced about Lou and we
offered these flowers into the ocean so
there were many many profound things
that happened during this time also
connected to my music Tyler and I were
recording in the Sun which is a song
that I wrote about you and I wrote about
the pressure of life and the financial
constriction and how hard it is in this
world you know especially for men to to
earn enough and be enough and succeed
and the chorus of this song was fly
daddy fly fly daddy fly and I had
written that chorus on a previous return
from the island of kawaii from doing
spiritual practice and I had asked for
the chorus and that's what was given so
years later after the boys and I
workshop this song over seven years in
many different forms Tyler and I even
had sung it on the Big Island during
that trip when you dnf'd we walked up to
the local music store and we played it
and sang it in the store and when we
finished we looked up and the shop owner
had broken down sobbing and tears and
she said I'm so sorry like you just it
touched me it touched me we walked out
and Tyler looked at me and he was like
okay that was good like as a musician if
you can make somebody cry with your song
like that's a good sign so here we were
the boys had said you know Mom we know
you wrote that song about rich but we
also think it's about Lou and it is it's
about everyman and so we would find out
later that when Lou called 911 he had a
heart attack on a kayak when he called
9-1-1 Tyler and I were actually
recording that exact song so the actual
recording on the album mother of mine is
the exact track at the moment that Lou
left his body that he left this world
and moved to another realm and what was
shown to me during that time when I met
Lou I was in an abusive marriage and I
was a battered woman I was on the out of
it I was coming out of it but that's the
truth that's the ugly truth and Lou
rescued me he truly was a rescuer that
was his archetype and that and he was a
fix-it man he was like I'm gonna fix
your life for you you know and he really
did my creative trajectory when I was
married to him was like a rocket I mean
I became an artist a fashion designer
started my own collection this was all
from being in a relationship where I
couldn't even take a step without
second-guessing myself and what I was
shown through this experience what I
felt is that Lou had rescued me in this
world and I had rescued him into the
other world
because I knew the spiritual essence and
the practices and the rituals and the
awareness to actually get him out of his
body and get him into the other realm
and the boys were sequestered here
safely at our sacred home at Jay house
we were recording music like it was it
just felt like it was all sort of
divinely planned and you know I haven't
spoken about it very much because it's a
very very private and very dear thing
but it was a profound experience that's
beautifully put
I remember I was out running on the
trails when my phone rang
he said you have to come home right now
and you told me what what had happened
yeah and the I'm going to try to say it
without without crying but um - it was a
horrifying experience to wake your
children up to tell him that story you
know and I remember we had a Ganesh and
I told Malthus ahead of time and Malthus
was much younger like five or six right
just turned six yeah so she was like mom
why are you crying where you're crying
and I told her I said I have to wake the
boys up and I have to tell them that
their dad is gone and I woke them up and
we gathered around the Ganesh and I
wrapped them in the Poncho's that we got
on our retreats in Mexico and you know I
told them and and hours afterwards I
went upstairs to take a bath and I
remember math is coming in little baby
and she said to me mama she said you did
the very best you could you did such a
good job you did the very best that you
could and that was just a you know a
beautiful beautiful moment of this
experience with our children and how
hell
amazing they are and how how powerful
they are and how wise they are and what
they offer us you know in those moments
[Music]